now we are seeing the big growth of
online the big growth of companies like
my science that
tools like ours are needed for the
online
and consumer journey and not just for
the the the
online business to make more money but
for the planet that we're living in
let's let's buy only one item let's buy
an item that we actually need
instead of buying three or four items or
five different pairs of shoes
because we know we can return it welcome
to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance
opposed hillel stanford leap and
birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders i'm joined
today by ronan luzon the founder and ceo
of my size inc
bonanno is a serial entrepreneur and a
skilled manager with the track record of
success across various industries
prior to founding my size he established
and led startups in the medical devices
and communication sectors
among his other endeavors ronan founded
mallors a company that has grown to be a
leader in the global security solutions
market
and provides some of the most advanced
technological solutions for integrated
communication infrastructure security
and control systems prior to that he
held several senior marketing sales
management
and professional services positions in a
variety of international high-tech
companies
london graduated from middlesex
university in london with a bsc in it
and business information systems
ronan luzon welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
i'm good good great to be here thank you
i'm really excited to have you here and
there's a lot for us to talk about both
on on the business side the leadership
side
you're you're currently the founder and
ceo of my size traded
first on the tel aviv stock exchange but
also on on
the new york stock exchange nasdaq mysd
and and i'm excited to to hear about
your personal journey but also the
journey of my size how you came up with
it
i believe it's a little bit of a
different industry than what you worked
in before and you you are
as a serial entrepreneur you've had your
hands full in quite a few industries and
i'm excited to hear a little bit about
the big milestones there and what you've
learned and so perhaps you can we can
start by you taking me back
a little bit throughout your life and
i'd love to hear of a few milestones and
and the the insights that you've gained
from them that lead you to where you are
today
uh what uh how far you want me to take
you
i'll fall back
so um it started as a kid i was
uh i was a stubborn kid i was kid didn't
want to learn and i was almost kicked
out of school on
10th grade wow and um
then my i only loved electronic
and uh the electricity that's the only
thing i've loved
and uh then the um when almost got
kicked out of school
my uh the the manager of the school
said look brought my my my parents
in and told my parents look ronan is a
brilliant kid
but he's he doesn't want to learn but
i'll give him two options
or he will go for the dancing group of
the school
me dancing like or is out this would be
on the street or
wherever and then i found myself dancing
in the dancing uh school of
uh of i i don't know if anybody knows
this this
story other than my wife and my kids um
and then i found myself
um as uh as a guy with
afro on his head now i don't have hair
at all but was afro back then
dancing in the in the dancing group of
the school in in
in hadera back then in israel and um
the years went by and and we were one of
the best
dancing group on uh in israel
and we amazing we found ourselves
uh traveling in germany and the uk and
france
demonstrating our beautiful dancing
skills all over the place
as uh and um i i finished school i
graduated school
and i continued to do
two extra years in engineering
because of the manager of the school
because he believed in me
and he gave me the option he gave me the
option of continuing
and uh in that that i called
stubbornness
stubbornness and believe in the other
person
and that that something that i took with
me
for for all the the rest of the years
that uh they're still here
and everybody i'm talking with all the
people that work for me or work with me
i always give them a second and third
option because you always look at the
men behind
behind wow the scene or behind that what
it reflects
because sometimes you have the person
attitude
but sometimes it's just a shield
sometimes it's just a shield to things
behind him
that you take some time to uh to figure
out and to understand
given the option give him the space
believe in him and then you get
the the real person came out that's
something that i've learned
many years ago um that's something on me
that uh that i take with me
uh from this manager who taught me
some uh how to be a human being not just
uh
just a manager not just an employee
i love just just a small story
after i graduated the army and
everything um i went to do my first
degree in the uk
i went with with a friend to do my first
degree in the uk and came back
started to work in uh
in the technology company in israel and
i started as a
programmer as an engineer and then i
took the steps from there and ended
after about
i think was 10 years that worked in this
company as a sales manager in uh on
on europe i worked in japan in the us
i traveled all around wow i met so many
people um
and so many different cultures it was
great great experience and then i've
started my uh um my
how to bring my ideas to life and i have
still have a lot of ideas different
ideas that
i always love to see how they come to
life
and i've built four different companies
two of them crushed and burned one
successful still working exactly where
we left off so you're
four companies two crashed and burned
one that is still running and and my
size
keep going and my size my size i started
uh
it started all when uh actually i've uh
i've ordered some
some my uh some garments for my kid
back then he was a big nba fan a big nba
for
the kid he was uh nine years old i don't
know if you can you can call him big nba
fan but still
so but he was keep changing his his
teams from
from lakers to boston like every month
there was a different different team and
we have to
buy him at different outfits um but when
buying different outfits we realized
that the sizes
are wrong and then we understood
that uh there is a problem here there's
a problem with
uh with the industry there's a problem
with uh with online
uh that was 2013 i i i
recall then we came up with this uh
what is my size that let's build
a unified id system that
will travel with each and every consumer
wherever you go
this is my id that's that's me that's my
my my body uh and please instead of
me looking for the right size at the the
right the brand
so the brand will give me the size that
i need
and then we came up with um with
using the mobile phone as a sensor based
as a ruler
as a measurement device for actually
measuring your body
then there is all this privacy issue you
don't want to uh
to take a picture of your kid by wearing
or not wearing any clothes or your wife
or yourself
for that matter and then we came up with
a sensor base so you just
move the phone so we don't use any
picture
based uh camera sensor sensor image
processing so just sensor just moving
the mobile phone
on on your body so for for instance if
you want to measure your height
just place the phone on the ground next
to your feet and pick it up with it on
your head
just by moving the phone from the ground
to your head we know to measure your
height
and the same thing we're doing for your
chest for your hips
and we're building your profile that's
how it's all started
um it's it sounds very easy but it's
it's not um and there were so many
as every every startup company there are
so many things that
that might go wrong everything you think
will uh that might go wrong
probably will go wrong and that's where
you need to put yourself
and um it took us almost five years to
develop this simple thing
that measuring with your mobile device
um and uh i i always
always believed and i still believe it's
a great idea and today would
we start selling and we have companies
like levi's and panty and us polo
using our system and using our solution
and showing such a great results
on decreasing returns and increasing
conversion and helping them actually
getting more revenues or even more
important making the
world that we're living here in much
more greener
in terms of just returns just uh
reducing the the amounts of shipment the
amount of logistics
getting the right size to the clients
this is one of the things that i think
it's very important
that combining actually technology
consumer journey
and the planet we're living in amazing
um
so that's one of the things that we're
doing in my science i have to ask you
know but just on that so
you're talking about the technology side
of it but i'm immediately curious about
the supply chain and how
how different apparel companies are
responding to it because essentially
you're saying
the way that we've been thinking about
sizes for the last hundred years or so i
don't know however long i'm getting
maybe even more than that
is is just upside down we have to shift
the the responsibility from the consumer
to the brand
we have to shift the the understanding
of how to measure size to be something
that is more personalized and
and unique to the individual and not
just
as a you know three-layer three-tiered
um categorized way tell me a little bit
about the perception from the
companies that how are they responding
to this idea
so you know sizes is is
such an easy thing that got so
complicated because of the breads
because of the consumers because of
everything to do with
how do we look at ourselves in the
mirror
and how the brands are mark marketing
their items to us as a consumers
and then it started as you have only
small medium large and extra large
and then all of the sudden small becomes
zero size
and all of the sudden zero became double
um and then it got all complicated and
why
because the brands wanted us to
when we're buying zero or when buying
double zero
it makes us look look better it makes us
feel better and buying garments is not
usually it's not something that you need
something that you want
it's something that comes from your gut
it's something that
it's you you're passionate all about
it's not that you need this
extra t-shirt or you need that extra
dress or you need that extra bra
nah not at all you want it um and
and that's and that's where the branding
and marketing is all about
and that's where sizing is this came and
what that's why today
levi's has different size chart and uh
and the victoria's secret have this
different size chart and
each and every brand has different size
chart from brand to brand
and if you're buying medium in puma
doesn't mean that you're medium adidas
and it's all across and that's why in
shoe sizes
you have about 70 returns 70
returns it's it's crazy um
and then if you put on top of that the
uh
the methods that like amazon brought to
the world that um
go ahead buy as much as you want
don't care about the shipment we will
pay for the shipment
take as much as you want measure it take
it try it on
whatever you don't want stand back we
will take care of the shipment we will
take off the payment
you don't care everything now amazon is
losing money
is new they are losing money on this
business but they want to get more
consumer on board
for the other businesses they want to
increase the traffic because they have
other things to take care about but
that's not the case with other retailers
that's not the case with 99 of the
retailers
they cannot cope with these losses they
cannot
believe in this market that gives
everything for
free and even even even far further
the planet that we're living in cannot
sustain
70 returns or 50
returns in germany or even 30 returns
this is crazy numbers this is numbers
that
the industry it's it's killing it
itself um and uh
since a few years ago before the covet
came
online was a very small part part
of the big brands if you take adidas for
example about 95
92 was the the revenue came from offline
stores
really when kovit came yeah wow yeah
when kovit came
in in one day on several days
95 92 of the sales of the revenues got
stopped because stores got closed wow
any other choice available need to buy
online and then we scratched ourselves
like
what size i'm i'm in adidas what kids i
need to
what size i need to buy for my kid
because
many of us are still buying offline um
and then we've seen the
the the the revenue start kicking from
the online as well
but as well the returns came off just
just afterwards
and then tools like my size tools like
uh like other consumer journey tools
that are helping
online retailers becomes a necessity
necessity must have tools in the online
world
and today you can see nike just their
online presence jumped in thirty percent
same with adidas and same with other
brands this is for the big one the small
one had the same type of phenomena
but now we are seeing the big growth of
online the big growth of companies like
my size that
tools like ours are needed for the
online
and consumer journey and not just for
the the the online
business to make more money but for the
planet that we're living in
let's let's buy only one item let's buy
an item that we actually need
uh instead of buying three or four items
or
five different pairs of shoes because we
know we can return it
let's buy one that actually will fit us
and and leave it with us
i love love the rationale tell me a
little bit about the business decision
to uh to go public on the television
stock exchange then going public on the
new york stock exchange remaining on the
television stock exchange
what was that thought process like for
you
so um my site is my first
company which is public all the other
were private completely private
and that the idea of
getting my size public from day one
was let's try this out because when i
started my size it was just a dream
i didn't have a product i just had an
idea that i need to start building and
still need to start writing
and when i started it there were several
articles
by google that a few years back that
says
the sensors inside the mobile phone are
not accurate enough to measure distances
and then we had when we went to vcs the
regular way that you uh that you
uh get money on on startup
is uh they said running it won't work
this this this this thing will not work
look at google look at this look at
these articles
the sensor thing will not work very hard
and the guys who actually want to give
money
they want to take so much percentage for
so little money that said
that will not work i will not stay and
this is an advice for you guys who want
to build a business
always think about round b round c
the next round of financing and how much
percentage
you will be left with managing your
company
because there is never in one round you
cannot get enough money to
get your company up and running so
always think about the next round and
stay with enough percentage in the
company so you can make money because
you're
clever enough to work as uh
uh as as a side wing in another company
and you will make enough salary and you
get your options and everything but if
you want to run your own business which
is
a lot of headache and a lot of
responsibility
stay with a big chunk of the company so
you can earn
as much as you need and you can still
take control
and have decisions inside the company so
always think about yourself
um so uh decided to
uh to get my size as a publicly traded
company
so to uh i bought a
shell it's a it's a shelf company that
was uh
stayed in the in the nest in the taste
uh stock market
and then we raised the money into it by
actually selling the dream
uh getting the dream pitch of the
company and where we and where it headed
and it actually worked people believed
they lived in the
in the story believed in uh in the
journey
invested money and we started uh traded
in tel aviv
stock exchange and we started uh working
and developing and
making this thing happen and in 2015 we
actually released the first
product which is just measuring surfaces
by moving the mobile phone
it's called size up you can download it
from the app store and for the google
play
uh for if you want a ruler inside your
mobile phone by the way it works better
than uh
then apple measure uh the measure app
it works much better you can check me
out
so 2015 we released that and in 2016 was
july 16
we've uplifted into nasdaq and i placed
it into nasdaq was the real dream
uh because the market is is in the u.s
the real investors are in the
um the ring clients are in the us that's
what we want to be
want to be where actually everything
happens and then we have uplifted into
nasdaq
and we raised the big chunk of money
uh from us investors from banks
uh from doing road shows and everything
to do with actually bringing
this story into uh the investor years
and uh and we got uh to up to date we've
uh
raised about 35 million dollars into the
company amazing
um and that's where we at
i love it ronan thank you so much for
joining me and telling me a story i have
so many more questions
and unfortunately i called this show 20
minute leaders i have three more
fun questions for you and so we'll get
to those
and i want to take you back to your
childhood what fascinated you as a kid
what
obviously it wasn't it wasn't school
from what i understand but what was
something that really
caught your attention and you were
passionate about
um i was always uh
a kid that uh didn't stay the same place
i always would like to disassemble
things
um and everything i found
uh i like to disassemble i never knew
how to assemble it back that was my that
that was the other part
and i keep putting out engines um
and uh of of of vehicles and of
motorbikes and uh i like to turn them
apart to take to see how it works from
the inside but when you tell me okay now
bring it back in
that was the hard part that i left it
there um
so one of the things i always uh wanted
as as as an older
older guy i learned how to bring them
back uh
uh these these parts back in now i
actually assemble it back in as a hobby
this relax relaxation uh part today i'm
uh
building things as well very very cool
and
where where do you gain inspiration from
today
where where does inspiration come to you
from
so i love to hear leaders live to heavy
leaders like
bill gates i love to hear uh uh other
leaders that are actually
paving the ways for uh or
interpreters like us uh from uh from
leaders
on the political side on the innovation
in
innovation side um i love to hear ted
talks on different things and that's
where i get my inspiration
from other other leaders that actually
done it where there made their mistakes
and actually knew how to get over it by
different things that they've done by
thinking out of the box
and not giving up um and and i always
say don't give up
even if you see hard things and being
getting a startup company up in the
areas is very hard you say
you hear no for so many times and i know
you hear it so for so
from so many people but when you're in
it and you're getting the first no in
the second no in the 10th now and the 50
no
you're almost about to give up don't
give up because if you believe in what
you do
stay with it it will it it will come up
it will come up and it will rise up
again and if you fail in the first
company
build the second one because that's the
only way to uh
to bring your ideas back to life amazing
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
huh um
i'm a people person um
i didn't like the coved i'm a people
person i like to be to be outside
to talk to people um second i'm very
stubborn
stubborn in what in what i love and i
always
love to understand why i get no for an
answer
and try to get around it and um
i'm i'm typically a sales guy if i was
reborn
my first job was to be a sales nut stand
work in front of a computer um that's
that's the things that i love
and i think about myself amazing
thank you very very much stay safe thank
you so much and thank you for sharing
this time with me i really appreciate it
thank you thank you have a great day
you